[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and with the dceu now
deceased I thought we'd take a look at
the feature and talk about the rumors on
what's going on with James Gunn's plan
in this video we're going to be breaking
down the update since our last one and
also giving our thoughts on the strategy
that Warner Brothers is taking and the
first thing I want to talk about is the
new DCU logo which leaked on Twitter
last week posts with it were getting
dmca by Warner Brothers so I don't want
to show it in the video but I can
describe it mate or you can Google it to
see just don't leave the video I said
don't leave and the logo has the blue DC
logo that's been used by the company for
the last couple of years in the middle
of it it says studio and to the left and
right we have the members of the Justice
League from left to right this is Green
Lantern Wonder Woman Superman Batman
Flash and lastly Aquaman now this
instantly lets us know that this will be
a strong Focus for the universe for the
Justice League being the main character
is that they're going to be pushing the
dceu of course took a strong focus on it
too and Warner Brothers pretty much
rushed out the Justice League movie so
that they could catch up with Marvel
didn't really work out and they've
actually delayed stuff to the point that
they're now having to reset the entire
universe just just to do it again
because they [ __ ] up so badly anyway
we have had some more info on Superman
and Wonder Woman With The Hollywood
Reporter saying that both Henry Cavill
and gal gadot's role in The Flash have
been completely cut out this was
something that was quite shocking to me
as I'd heard from my sources that gal
was actually a big part of the scenes
that she was in Henry's Bar took quite
small and they were added back in
September however the Wonder Woman's
role wasn't going to be a massive part
of the movie there were a lot of more
poignant moments that featured her in it
now this was leader debunked by Twitter
account The Flash Film news who said
that the scenes with gal did in fact
remain honestly I don't think DC no for
death know what they're doing yet and
with the movie releasing in June it's
possible that they'll do multiple cuts
of it and screen it to audiences now
beyond that Daniel rpk posted last night
that Gal Gadot was no longer going to be
playing Wonder Woman and that we would
definitely getting a full reboot gal was
the kind of person I think was gonna be
the one that indicated this along with
Jason Momoa we've of course had both
Henry and Cavill being people that were
in and out of DC at several points over
the last couple of years and Ray Fisher
was no longer part of the universe
either all this stuff with Ezra Miller
made it pretty much impossible for the
studio to keep working with him and
there's all that remained from the
league were Momoa and gal if either of
them could go then they could all go and
yeah if this is true then that
definitely means they're all out now
from what I've been told Zachary Levi is
also out of Shazam and this is before
his next movie even releases now I've
said this in another video and I got
some backlash but I'm gonna say it again
I think that doing this big announcement
before the release of Shazam 2 The Flash
and Aquaman 2 is a stupid mistake as it
will make these movies pretty pointless
to see now what backlash did I get from
saying that well the main thing is that
shared universes have kind of things and
that if a movie is good then it doesn't
matter if it's part of the universe or
not totally agree and that's a valid
point but when the movie is part of a
shared Universe already then I think it
can have detrimental effects let's be
honest though most people that we're
gonna see those movies will probably
still go see them there will be a number
of those that don't because they just
aren't interested in these characters on
their own it could end up costing Warner
Brothers a couple of million dollars so
to me it was a stupid thing to do when
they still have three movies that
they're releasing a shared universe is
in general tend to work this way you
have your big characters and the movies
that people are definitely gonna see
however what this studio then do is that
they push these lesser known ones that
people normally wouldn't bother to go
out and see if it wasn't part of the
Universe Marvel of Bank done this as
well and there's a lot of characters in
the MCU that are really obscure but
General audiences have given them
attention because they feel they need to
see their movie in order to understand
the greatest story I'll always give
props to Marvel for what they did with
Captain Marvel and they dropped it right
between Infinity war and endgame because
as they knew people would go see the
movie to understand the post-credits
scene of the former film and get an idea
of what could happen in endgame Captain
Marvel made 1.2 billion at the box
office making it even more successful
than the first Wonder Woman movie so
with all that being said that's why I
think it's a stupid idea to announce it
and why it's probably pointlessing those
movies now for most people sure flash
Shazam and Aquaman Mega fans that
they're gonna be there day one and I'm
guessing that a lot of DC fans in
general will too but they kind of cut
off the marker that only care about shed
movie universes which might not be
massive but it's probably going to be
substantial enough that it's gonna stop
these films from doing the higher box
office numbers that occurred if it was
part of the same universe you went full
reboot never go full reboot however
saying that the box office for Black
Adam has shown that maybe the interest
for DC in general just isn't there and
this is why they've decided to scrap it
all completely rather than trying to
salvage something that might not work
going forward I think it's a big big ask
for fans though who've been told to be
patient for the last 10 years because DC
they're building towards something big
to now just be told yeah no nothing's
going anywhere but uh give us another 10
years now gonna start discussing what's
gonna be in a Superman film and we have
some minor details about what he wants
to do I think when we look back at the
dceu then it's very clear what happened
early on to make the universe the way it
was The Dark Knight trilogy had just
been a massive success a Man of Steel
was sort of in the same mold as that
with it being a more down-to-earth
Superman that had a more grounded tone
to it Nolan was of course a producer on
it and they even got David S guy to help
write it who was also the ride out on
some of the Dark Knight movies now by
the sounds of it they're doing something
similar to that but instead of The Dark
Knight trilogy they're using the Batman
as the sort of format for the future the
Batman was a year two story that already
had the character set up and from here
they could just hit the ground running
from what I've been told about the
Superman story it's gonna be pretty much
the same as that out with it centering
on a young Clark Kent who's just arrived
at Metropolis it'll focus on him
reporting meeting Lois hiding his secret
and so on and so forth you know you know
what it is the usual now this is similar
to how Batman met Catwoman for the first
time and it's clear that they're doing
that sort of dynamic as the secret to
success gonna stated several times that
the reason he couldn't cast caval for
this is because he wanted a young
Superman but Cavill is about 39 years
old and he doesn't really look it so a
lot of people were like what the hell
mate now I think what gun has done is
stupid however I can see why he's
probably done this because they want
this universe going forward for the next
10 years and by the time it's all
wrapped up the dceu actors will be a lot
older I know people have said you could
just the age him but it adds a lot onto
the budget so I can see why the studio
have just done what they've done now
personally I think the way they've
treated Cavill is super [ __ ] up and
that it might even be something that
bites them in the butt down the line the
whole way they situations played out
with him has been a pretty bad one and
it might just put a number of people off
because of the way that things were
handled Now Kevin actually auditioned
for Superman all the way back with
Superman Returns he lost out to Brandon
Routh but years later he managed to land
his dream job for Man of Steel it's one
of my favorite DC EU movies but mixed
reviews and a box office that didn't
deliver the billions one were expecting
it made them think twice Batman v
Superman was up next and though a Warner
Brothers screeding of it got a standing
ovation the studio decided to mess
around and cut half an hour from it
Suicide Squad was given to a trailer
company to cut and we'll be here all day
if we talk about what happened with
Justice League we then had the Headless
Superman for Shazam and this would later
be followed up by The Cameo and
Peacemaker in which he was basked in
Shadow out of the light the whole time
Cavill is getting messed around and it
wouldn't be until 2022 that a glimmer of
hope really came back Shoei had the
Snyder cup but comments by the execs and
the fact there wasn't really any further
movement in that universe made fans
think that he was getting messed around
as well how about the rock pulled some
strings behind the scenes and he got
Henry Cavill back to shoot a cameo in
Black Adam from the rumors surrounding
this we have a rough idea what happened
with him and he was basically brought
back told they were doing cameos for
Black Adam in The Flash and that man of
steel was being greenlit and worked on
this is true too as we know this script
was in early development and though it's
not the reason given why Kabul left The
Witcher I think you'd be lying to
yourself if you didn't think there was
at least some some bearing on his
decision with all this included now
Cavill was also told to put out an
announcement on social media saying that
he was back and you can totally see why
he'd be in the mind state that this was
all locked in but that cavil was then
called into a room and told that
everything he'd been told was happening
no longer was and that he was out pretty
brutal way to handle it especially with
it now apparently coming out that gun
was actually working on the Superman
script per month as caval was being told
that he was in it has the potential to
start the new universe off on a really
bad footing and I think the only way to
Silence the Critics is for this to
actually work now I think in order for
all this to work that the upcoming
Superman movie needs to be one of the
best comic book movies of all time I'm
talking casting directing the bloody
script that people died for all of it if
it's even average then it's going to be
completely torn apart because we've had
to throw everything out for it I don't
even know if they should have announced
an entire movie Universe before making
the first movie either because if this
fails then it's all [ __ ] as well I
don't know why Studios time and time
again do this and to me they they should
have just did what they did with the
Batman and Joker and say that it was
completely disconnected from everything
then you don't have the pressure that
there's movies down the line resting on
it and it can just be its own thing
again kind of ties back to that shared
Universe thing from before where it can
really be a double-edged sword I also
think gonna need to do a full reboot no
messing about and get rid of both peace
Peacemaker and Suicide Squad as well
really like those movies and shows but
it will be pure nepotism if he keeps the
universe's wife is in and I think if he
cuts it then it will show actual
leadership and that he's not just trying
to get people close to him advantages
when the big names are all being thrown
out I'm saying that what what's Sean go
and get cast as Bruce Wayne or something
I tell you so so who knows what's gonna
happen and I think that out of all the
people working in Hollywood at the
moment that James Gunn is probably one
of the only handful of people that can
pull this off there's just a lot of
pressure to hit a home run and if it
even Falls slightly short of that then
there's gonna be people complaining that
they threw away a lot of things just to
get more the same but with different
actors so yeah that's all the updates or
opinion and basically basically is
moaning about some first world problems
obviously though we're here at moan all
saying nice things and I'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you drop a
comment below and let me know we are any
competition right now and giving away
Dawn of the Dead and Black Adam the
three subscribers on the 15th of January
and all you have to do to be when the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts and theories on what's going to
be happening if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our last ECU breakdown which will be
linked on screen right now lots of
things going on with it it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting to see it all
plays out and yeah definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for sticking through the video Happy
Paul I'll see you next time take care
peace